Тиша й порожнеча в Верховній Раді.
Складається враження, що після президентських виборів
парламент дещо розгублений. Депутати не знають,
чого очікувати від майбутнього президента України Володимира Зеленського.
Найбільше їх непокоїть, чи розпустить
новий очільник держави парламент.
Такі побоювання не безпідставні.
Нині Володимир Зеленський не має впливу
ані в парламенті, ані в уряді. Це суттєво ускладнює
його стартові позиції як людини, яка пообіцяла "зламати систему".
Адже для того, щоб зняти недоторканність
із депутатів, президента й суддів - а саме ці
законодавчі ініціативи Зеленський напередодні виборів
називав своїми пріоритетними кроками в разі обрання -
йому необхідна парламентська більшість у Верховній Раді.
Без парламентської більшості з 226 депутатів
новообраний президент не зможе ініціювати урядових перестановок.
Тому у прем'єр-міністра Володимира Гройсмана,
призначеного Верховної Радою за поданням президента Порошенка,
є всі шанси досидіти до наступних парламентських виборів в країні.
- Доброго дня, шановні колеги.
Сам Гройсман, до речі, не проти залишитися на посаді.
Нині він помітно відмежовується від команди
екс-президента Петра Порошенка й сигналізує
готовність до співпраці з новим главою держави.
- Маленький бюлетень великого майбутнього.
Без парламентської більшості Зеленський не зможе
затвердити кандидатури низки ключових високопосадовців:
міністрів оборони та закордонних справ,
генпрокурора, голови СБУ тощо.
Все, що може зробити президент без підтримки парламенту, -
це призначити очільника своєї адміністрації,
секретаря та заступників Ради національної безпеки і оборони,
нового керівника Генштабу тощо.
Два тижні тому в Верховній Раді створили
міжфракційне об’єднання "За Зеленського".
Щоправда, поки що туди входить лише один депутат - Віталій Купрій.
На думку експертів, ще кілька десятків депутатів
можуть перейти до Зеленського. Але цього все одно
не достатньо для ухвалення законів і проведення обіцяних реформ.
Така політична безсилість може суттєво зіпсувати
рейтинг Володимира Зеленського до парламентських виборів,
які мають відбутися восени. Тому йому були б
вигідні дострокові вибори до парламенту
на хвилі успіху після президентських. Раніше
Зеленський уже заявляв, що подумає про розпуск парламенту,
якщо стане президентом.
Згідно з українським законодавством,
є три підстави для розпуску Верховної Ради президентом:
неможливість сформувати новий склад Кабінету міністрів
після відставки старого, відсутність пленарних засідань парламенту
протягом 30 днів або нездатність сформувати
парламентську коаліцію протягом 30 днів.
Нині в Україні фактично відсутня парламентська коаліція.
Ще в лютому 2016 року фракції "Самопоміч" та "Батьківщина"
вийшли з коаліції "Європейська Україна",
тож формально там залишилися лише дві фракції:
"Блок Петра Порошенка" та "Народний фронт".
Разом це 219 депутатів з необхідних 226.
Інше питання - часові рамки. Швидше за все,
Зеленський вже просто не встигне розпустити парламент.
В останні 6 місяців роботи Верховної Ради
до планових виборів зробити це вже неможливо.
Чинний склад парламенту набув повноважень 27 листопада 2014 року,
тобто після 27 травня скористатись цим правом президент вже не зможе.
Згідно з актуальними даними опитувань,
партія Зеленського "Слуга народу",
навіть не оголосивши імена своїх провідних кандидатів,
нині з відривом лідирує за симпатіями виборців.
Тим часом до осені Володимир Зеленський
може суттєво розгубити свій 70-відсотковий рейтинг підтримки виборців.
І це шанс для Порошенка або для нової
анонсованої політичної сили Гройсмана зайти в Верховну Раду переможцями.